You once mentioned you were planning on
making an Iq test available alongside
the big five aspects scale.
One,
is that in the works?
Yes,
we have an Iq test that we use for
business testing.
Um,
although we haven't made it available
publicly yet.
It is in the works but not for a while
what we're doing instead.
And that's because it has to be while
there's a bunch of work we still have to
do on it to generate the report so that
they're going to be truly usable to
people.
Now that I would say is about three or
four months.
Work is necessary to do that.
Um,
what we are doing right now with the big
five aspect scale though.
So that's how understand myself.com is
producing a dyad version.
And so we're working on the boyfriend
girlfriend version right now.
So what that'll mean is that when you go
there and you do your personality test
and your girlfriend say,
does her personality test that you'll
both be able to generate a dual report
that describes the similarities and
differences between you and your partner
and where you're likely to see eye to
eye on things where you're likely to
defer and what that's going to mean and
what you might want to do about it.
If you know what you might be able to do
about it.
And this we're hoping this will be
really useful because temperamental
differences are a lot of the reason that
people have a hard time getting along
that and complete inability whatsoever
to state what they actually want and to
negotiate.
Which is a completely different issue.
I want to build a program to help people
negotiate to at some point in the
future.
That's part of our future plan,
but the next development plan is to.
Well,
there's two of them is to get the high
school version of the cell phone program
up and running and that my program or
keeps promising it in two weeks and I.
These things always take longer than
expected,
but I'm sure we'll get it out in the
first quarter of 2018 and then also the
dyad version of the big five aspects
scale that should be out in the first
quarter of 2018 as well.
And then I'm not sure if the Iq test
will be next on the development track.
See,
one of the things we'd like to do with
understand myself is to expand it out
into a career I'm planning process
because look at it this way.
You know if you have an Iq of 100,
which is the average Iq,
so that would place you sort of in the
middle of the average high school class.
Being a lawyer is probably not a great
career choice for you unless you're
unbelievably conscientious because
you're going to be competing with people
who have a verbal facility say and a
problem solving capacity that far
exceeds yours.
And you're going to have to work like
mad to just be reasonably competent.
And so what seems to be more logical is
to take a good look at your intellectual
prowess as given because it's very
powerfully biologically influenced and
to pick a domain of,
of career that you could excel in
because why not pick a domain that you
can excel and there's lots of different
things that you can be.
And so you want to consult your
temperament.
So if you're agreeable,
then you probably want to work with
people.
And if you're disagreeable,
you probably want to work with things.
And if you're extroverted,
you want to have a job that involves
sales and social activity.
And if you're introverted,
you want to work alone.
And if you're open,
you need to do something creative and
entrepreneurial and so on.
So you have to consult your temperament
to see where you would be properly
slotted.
And then you have to consider your
intelligence so that you can find a
niche where you're most likely to excel.
And those niches exists.
So we'd like to combine the Iq test with
the big five aspects scale.
So that we can give people reasonable
career advice.
It's been a longterm goal and so those
are all on the table and I have good
program team working on them,
but they're very complicated things and
they take a lot of time and we don't
want to make a mistake and all of that.
So.
But maybe the couples version and the
high school version of the couple's
version of the personality test and the
high school version of the self
authoring in this quarter and maybe
maybe the career counseling version of
the big five aspects scale in the next
year.
That would be lovely.
That's probably overly optimistic for
the second part,
but.